ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video oggi
risponderò alle vostre supposizioni nei
miei confronti a tutte quelle cose che
pensate di sapere su di me in questi
giorni infatti su instagram vi ho
chiesto di scrivermi delle affermazioni
o delle appunto supposizioni che vi
siete fatti in questi anni seguendomi
sulla mia vita sul mio modo di
affrontare insomma le cose le cose
brutte e sulle mie passioni eccetera
eccetera
quindi oggi affermerò o negherò tutte
queste supposizioni
prima di partire col video però ho una
comunicazione importantissima da farvi
siete pronti il tour del firmacopie di
cuore corazza sta per sbarcare a ROMA
sono felicissima perché finalmente vengo
a Roma a incontrarvi é da tantissimo tempo
che mi chiedete una data a Roma quindi
segnatevi tutti questa data sabato 9
marzo cioè il sabato che sta per venire
alle ore 16 a partire dalle ore 16 alla
libreria mondadori di via tuscolana 771
io non vedo l'ora di abbracciarvi quindi
non mancate e vi aspetto
partiamo subito con la prima cosa che
pensate di sapere su di me sei rifatta
no perché questa supposizione non sono
rifatta non ho niente di rifatto
alcuni di voi mi hanno chiesto se ho
rifatto gli zigomi
no sono miei naturali e per adesso non
mi sono mai fatta neanche punturine cose
varie quindi sono proprio nature come mi
vedete come mamma m'ha fatto
ami molto gli animali e vorresti un cane
ebbene sì è verissimo amo gli animali ho
un nipotino a quattro zampe da quattro
mesi che ha preso mia sorella e mi
sono follemente innamorata e a maggior
ragione ancora di più sto pensando
insomma di fare questa scelta di
prendere un cane con me anche se é
comunque una responsabilità è molto
impegnativo e voglio pensarci bene
essere molto sicura non ti butti giù al
primo ostacolo più o meno
nel senso che inizialmente tendo ad
andare in down quindi a più chiudermi in me stessa a vedere tutto nero per magari
un giorno due dopo di che riesco sempre a
trovare la forza per andare avanti e per
cercare di superare quell'ostacolo
non ti chiami maryna è vero non mi
chiamo maryna con la y
mi chiamo marina senza y tanti di voi lo
sapranno il mio nome vero é marina
con la i normale ho deciso di mettere
questa y per differenziare un pó la
marina ragazza dalla marina personaggio
pubblico diciamo una delle tue passioni
più grandi é il canto assolutamente sì
chi mi segue su instagram avrà visto che
pubblico spesso cover storie in cui canto
adoro ovviamente la musica e mi piace
tantissimo cantare
tant'è che uno dei miei sogni é anche quello insomma di fare una canzone di diventare
una cantante perché no e chi ha letto
cuore corazza il mio romanzo avrà
intuito qualcosa quindi assolutamente
si sei molto emotiva sì questa è una
caratteristica del mio fantastico segno
zodiacale il cancro che é emotivo lunatico
sensibile ecco io sono perfettamente in
linea con le caratteristiche del mio
segno e sono così tanto emotiva che
spesso mi capita magari di vedere delle
pubblicità in tv a piangere ma tipo
pubblicità che non dovrebbero fare
piangere ma io mi emoziono mi
basta niente per emozionarmi anche magari a
volte sono in giro e vedo non so due
vecchietti che si tengono per la mano e mi
sale proprio il groppone qui il piantino sono
fatto così sei molto disorganizzata e
fai tutto all'ultimo minuto anche questo
è super vero purtroppo
io vi assicuro che è da anni anni e anni
forse dal liceo che io ogni anno
compro un'agenda e a fine anno
quell'agenda è completamente vuota non
c'è scritto niente perché io mi
riprometto di organizzarmi tutti gli
anni di scrivere gli appuntamenti e le cose di lavoro poi non la apro neanche cioè ho la
pila di agende così degli anni passati
mai utilizzati io sono proprio la
disorganizzazione fatta a persona mangi
un sacco anche se sei magra come un
chiodo
allora innanzitutto ci tengo a precisare
questa cosa visto che spesso me lo
dicono sotto le foto che sono troppo
magra sono veramente così di costituzione
infatti chi mi segue vede le storie vede
che mangio sempre un sacco
sono fortunata ho un metabolismo che
lavora molto bene e quindi tutto quello
che mangio a quanto pare lo brucio ci
sono rimasta abbastanza male quando è
capitato di leggere sotto le mie foto
sei anoressica sei pelle ossa mangia le ossa le diamo ai cani questi commenti
veramente imbarazzanti e ridicoli
innanzitutto perché appunto come ho
appena detto sono fatta così di
costituzione quindi non posso non lo
decido io
seconda cosa ricordiamoci che anoressia
bulimia
tutti questi problemi legati al cibo
sono problemi seri gravi determinati
soprattutto da fattori psicologici non è
assolutamente un argomento sul quale
scherzare insultare e un argomento da
sminuire con un commento cretino su
instagram quindi evitate di farlo sei
stata adottata
no anche se fosse
non ci sarebbe nessun problema perché
sono super favorevole alle adozioni ho
un'amica che è stata adottata quindi so
cosa vuol dire so quanto siano
coraggiosi e pieni d'amore i genitori
che decidono insomma di allargare la
loro famiglia di adottare un bambino
nonostante non ci sia un legame di
sangue e so anche quanto possono essere
fortunati i bambini che vengono accolti
in in una situazione di questo tipo
perché spesso sono tolti da situazioni
difficili nelle quali non avrebbero
assolutamente avuto modo di ricevere
amore di crescere come ogni bambino si
merita di crescere in passato sei stata
più timida e introversa di ora sì e no
nel senso che su alcuni aspetti da
ragazzina ero più timida introversa su
altri no mi rendo conto sempre più
crescendo che ero molto più sfrontata di
adesso mi faceva molti meno problemi
adesso boh forse per insomma il lavoro che faccio il contesto in cui mi trovo
spesso devo un attimo filtrare quello
che penso perché come sapete sono molto
diretta
quindi per evitare problemi e
discussioni spesso magari mi tengo
dentro quello che penso i tuoi sono
divorziati da quando sei piccola sì nel
senso che si sono separati quando io ero
molto piccola forse 1-2 anni non ricordo
e poi più di recente hanno divorziato sei
spagnola per metà nel senso che mia
mamma é italiana e mio papá  é spagnolo
si sono conosciuti a londra
ovviamente quando erano giovani e per
questo motivo io parlo sia italiano che
spagnolo quindi per tutti coloro che non
lo sapessero visto che spesso magari
faccio stories in spagnolo video in
spagnolo papá parla spagnolo quindi l'ho
imparato in questo modo non ho mai
studiato diciamo ti descrivo in una sola
parola : vera innazitutto grazie perché è una
delle cose che mi rende più orgogliosa
sapere che sono riuscita a farmi vedere
da voi per quello che sono veramente
nonostante insomma faccia tanti
personaggi nei miei video mi mascheri faccia imitazioni
l'importante è che sia uscita la vera me
questa cosa mi riempie il cuore di gioia
penso che sui social sia fondamentale essere se
stessi perché per quanto uno possa
fingere di essere qualcosa che non è
prima o poi la verità viene sempre a
galla e ci vuole un attimo perché la
maschera cada per terra e si rompa in mille
pezzi facendo vedere quello che si cela
veramente dietro ad essa inizialmente
sembri una che se la tira ma poi
conoscendoti non è affatto così
allora
questa è una cosa che prima insomma di
affacciarmi al mondo dei social succedeva
spesso nelle mie relazioni
interpersonali
la maggior parte dei miei amici dei miei
passati ragazzi mi dicevano sempre la prima volta che ti ho visto ho pensato quanto se la tira questa
poi conoscendoti ho
cambiato completamente idea
ecco io non ho mai capito bene questa
cosa ma forse adesso a distanza di anni
la verità è che appunto io spesso ho una
corazza un pó da stronza un pó da dura
che uso utilizzo per cercare di
proteggermi perché non sono una persona
che si fida sono molto diffidente e
quindi metto questo scudo tra me e gli
altri
e la cosa tra virgolette bella ma molto
difficile é che soltanto chi va dietro
lo scudo riesce a conoscermi veramente
e quelli invece che si fermano davanti
allo scudo e girano i tacchi e se ne vanno
via evidentemente non hanno questo
grande interesse di conoscermi ed è
meglio perderli che trovarli
secondo me sei una persona che cerca di
coprire le debolezze e vuole sempre
portare positività
sì è vero tanti di voi mi chiedono come
fai a essere sempre così carica così
positiva così felice la mia risposta è
no non lo sono sempre anche io ho i miei
momenti no ma non voglio tra virgolette
condividerli con voi non voglio
farvi vedere le mie debolezze perché
voglio cercare di trasmettere
sempre positività e forza a chi mi segue
sei super gelosa
immagino che chi ha scritto questa questa
affermazione intenda con i ragazzi
come sapete ho fatto tanti video sulla
gelosia sulle ragazze gelose c'ho sempre
scherzato e riso su perché è una cosa
che nel bene o nel male riguarda tante ragazze
però se vi devo dire la verità forse una
volta quando ero più piccola ero un pó più
gelosa adesso non lo sono più e secondo
me la gelosia delle ragazze dipende
tanto dalla persona con cui stanno perché
in passato ho avuto ragazzi che non mi
davano insomma sicurezza è infatti ero
gelosa perché avevo magari più dubbi
non mi fidavo eccetera eccetera
adesso ho un ragazzo che non mi fa
dubitare di niente non ha segreti
mi fido di lui al 100 per cento e
infatti non sono gelosa quindi penso che
tutta questa gelosia delle ragazze
dipende essenzialmente dalla persona che
hanno al loro fianco quando eri adolescente non
accettavi il tuo corpo
si vero quando ero adolescente ero
forse dieci chili in più e non mi
piacevo assolutamente anche perché le
mie compagne erano tutte magre con i
fisici perfetti tutte belle toniche ci
provavamo i costumi e io guardavo loro
e dicevo perchè loro sono così e io così è
tutto normalissimo ragazzi è
normalissimo durante l'adolescenza avere
dei chili in più é normalissimo avere  i brufoli
perché è un periodo di transizione della
nostra vita
quindi non vi fate problemi inutili il
consiglio che vi posso dare se siete
insomma nel bel mezzo l'adolescenza e non
andate d'accordo con il vostro corpo è
innanzitutto di concentrarvi sui vostri
pregi e sappiate che questo è un periodo
di transizione il vostro corpo non
rimarrà così il vostro corpo muterà e
non potete sapere in quale farfalla
meravigliosa vi tramuterete
sei una persona molto selettiva hai pochi
veri amici assolutamente sì c'è stato un
periodo della mia vita in cui avevo
tantissimi amici tre quarti dei quali
falsi come giuda
quindi dopo tutte le delusioni e tutti
gli amici insomma che mi hanno tradito
ho deciso ho preso questa decisione
meglio pochi ma buoni quindi sì ho pochi
amici ma super buoni e li tengo stretti
perché sono davvero preziosi hai scritto
un libro si è uscito da pochissimo si
chiama cuore corazza è un romanzo una
storia e sono fierissimo di questo
progetto perché era uno dei sogni che
insomma volevo realizzare
sto ricevendo tantissimi messaggi super
positivi il libro vi sta piacendo
tantissimo e io sono veramente veramente
felice allora la supposizione più
gettonata è questa scritta ovviamente in
modi diversi perché siete stati in
tantissimi a scrivermela nella vita hai
passato molte disavventure che però ti
hanno aiutato a crescere e ad essere più
forte che ho passato molte disavventure é
vero che ho avuto dei periodi veramente
veramente bruttini anche più che grazie
alla mia ironia
penso che sia più stato la forza che a
un certo punto è scattata dentro di me
la forza insomma di cambiamento di
riuscire a non farmi più tra virgolette
schiacciare da determinate situazioni di
non farmi più mettere i piedi in testa da
nessuno di essere me stessa al cento per
cento e lottare per i miei sogni perché
solo io posso farlo e non ho bisogno di
nessun altro
da piccola sei stata bullizzata sì anche io
insomma ho vissuto episodi di bullismo è
un argomento delicatissimo di cui oggi
grazie a dio si parla molto soprattutto
grazie ai social anche se proprio grazie
ai social
si è diffuso ancora di più sappiamo
tutti che cos'è il cyberbullismo sapete
che è un argomento che mi sta molto a
cuore di cui parlo spesso bisogna
parlarne tantissimo perché bisogna
provare a combatterlo non è possibile
che sia così diffuso e che soprattutto
rovini le vite a tantissimi ragazzini
so che tanti di voi sono insomma vittime
di bullismo me lo scrivete spesso in
direct nei messaggi quello che vi posso
consigliare dal profondo del cuore é di
parlarne o con i vostri genitori con
dei vostri amici o con gli insegnanti
non dovete assolutamente avere paura di
parlarne perché non è giusto quello che
state subendo non dovete essere vittime
di nessuno quindi parlatene e non
sentitevi mai in colpa perché non avete
fatto niente di male siete perfetti così
come siete e nessuno si deve permettere
di insultarvi e di farvi del male
verbale o fisico siamo arrivati
purtroppo alla fine del video spero
tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto e che
abbiate avuto modo insomma di conoscermi
un pó meglio se questo video vi è
piaciuto vi chiedo per favore di
lasciarmi un bel like e se non vi siete
ancora iscritti al canale
iscrivetevi e cliccate sulla campanella
che trovate vicino al tasto d'iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica
tutte le volte che pubblico un nuovo
video ricordatevi inoltre dell'appuntamento
di sabato 9 marzo alle ore 16 alla
mondadori di via tuscolana 771 a Roma
non vedo l'ora di vedervi seguitemi
su tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram ei tiktok e soprattutto su
instagram perché comunicherò tutte le
prossime date dei firmacopie proprio lì
vi mando un bacione enorme e top adoro ciao